et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
David lissnard bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous mer les
républicains de can président de
l'Association des maires de France on va
évidemment longuement parler de ce
congrès des maires qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui qui se tient toute la
semaine et qui a pour thème les communes
attaquées la République menacé on va y
revenir pour vous à mes côté
Jean-Baptiste foret bonjour
Jean-Baptiste merci d'être avec nous
Jean-Baptiste rédacteur en chef délégué
à la Gazette des communes on va
évidemment parler des des enjeux de ce
congrès des mères et ils sont nombreux
mais d'abord dans l'actualité ce sont
ces plus de 100 1700 pardon actes
antisémites qui ont eu lieu dans notre
pays depuis le 7 octobre il y a quelques
jours un maire du Var a retrouvé une
croix gamée sur son domicile quelle
réponse on apporte face à cette
recrudesence des actes antisémites David
lisen la réponse doit être d'AB bord
régalienne évidemment c'estàd que dans
dans l'urgence il y a une nécessité
d'enquête et de répression euh
l'antisémitisme c'est pas
anodin c'est c'est un délit grave lourd
donc la réponse elle doit d'abord être
régalienne mais elle est aussi forcément
moral et spirituel hein si vous me
permettez le mot euh j'ai enfin
quelqu'un de ma génération a été éduqué
à la lutte contre toute forme de racisme
et donc contre tout jugement d'un
individu non pas sur ce qu'il fait mais
sur ce qu'il est et c'est ce qui
caractérise l'universalisme républicain
c'est c'est un trésor d'ailleurs cet
universalisme républicain qui un
substrat qui qui qui remonte enfin voilà
c'est un substrat de philosophie grecque
de droit romain de culture
giddéochchrétienne d'esprit des lumières
toutes ces choses qui étaient en
contradiction ont créé cet universalisme
républicain et aujourd'hui l'impression
que j'ai que j'ai eu moi quand j'ai vu
ces images de croix gamé des des étoiles
de David sur des immeubles enfin c'est
on a impression 80 ans d'éducation à la
lutte contre
l'antisémitisme on est enfin la chois
c'était pas c'était la génération de nos
parents de nos grands-parents quoi je
c'est c'est tout proche ont été balayés
donc il y a il y a du travail quoi il y
a du travail et pour montrer que qu'en
France on ne fait qu'un peuple quel que
soi nos croyances et nos origines et ça
va être l'enjeu colossal des prochaines
années oui on parle de du Congrès des
mèes le président de la République ne
viendra pas prononcer le discours de
clôture de ce con mais sa présence était
envisagée au salon des mares est-ce
qu'il sera là d'après les dernières de
ce que j'ai lu y compris ce matin il ne
sera pas là voilà vous le regrettez bon
nous on est toujours très honoré
d'accueillir le président de la
République quel qu'il soit
euh mais bon c'est le Congrès des MRES
c'est pas le congrès de l'Élysée donc on
a on a un congrès qui s'annonce record
en terme de de fréquentation dès
aujourd'hui sur la journée des outres
mèes d'ailleurs euh que vous évoquez
tout à l'heure euh on a on a 40 débats
alors qu'on avait 30 l'année dernière il
y a 230 de mémoire intervenant euh nous
aurons au moins 15 ministres qui ont
confirmé leur présence dans des débats
plus la première ministre avec qui on
travaille de façon fluide même si on ne
partage pas toutes les dispositions
gouvernementales hein donc on a é vous
dites c'est pas le congrès de l'Élysée
parce que le fait qu'il reçoivent des
maires à l'Élysée plutôt que de venir
vous voir pour vous c'est pas une bonne
chose non mais j'ai je vous le dis très
franchement euh il est pas obligé de
venir tous les ans au Congrès des mes
moi j'ai toujours dit c'est lui qui
avait dit qu'il virait tous les ans mais
on demandez pas euh donc je vais pas à
moi à chaque fois tous les ans de ir
parler de la venue ou pas du président
s'il vient il est bienvenu s'il ne vient
pas voilà les présents ont raison voilà
c'est tout ce que je peux vous dire où
en sont de manière générale les
relations entre l'Association des merdes
de France et le pouvoir macronien le
numéro 2 de l'Association des maires de
France Monsieur leniel dit que le
gouvernement vous caresse les chines en
vous sent les poches oui c'est sont les
formules dans lniel qui sont souvent
très percutantes
d'ailleurs écoutez nous on personnalise
pas les Ch enfin moi en tout cas je
personnalise pas les choses et à la MF
personne nous travaillons sur la réalité
qui est la nôtre donc les difficultés
que nous rencontrons en tant que maire
dans la relation avec l'État mais nous
sommes aussi nous-même une partie de
l'état donc notre seule préoccupation
c'est de faire des propositions pour que
les communes qui sont pour nous un
élément de la modernité de la France et
non pas une ringardise comme certains
peut-être nous voient hein déconnecté de
la vie réelle soit VIVANTE nos communes
et que nous apportions une solution de
performance publique parce que notre
pays est quand même face à une réalité
étourdissante c'est nous avons le record
du monde de la dépense publique c'est
incontournable ça on peut penser ce que
l'on veut c'est entre 56 % et 58 % de la
richesse il y a pas l'équivalent en
France et pourtant des service publics
de proximité qui se délit et nous
estimons que face à cet excès de de de
bureaucratie qui étouffe l'action
publique qui se fait au détriment des
fonctionnaires au détriment des usagers
au détriment des contribuables une des
solutions c'est la la responsabilité
locale nous travaillons avec le
gouvernement de façon fluide euh en tout
cas le gouvernement borne plus fluide
qu'avec des précédents gouvernement on
n'est pas d'accord sur un certain nombre
de choses l'AMF c'est pas le président
moi-même et le premier visprésident ce
sont tous les maires de France dans nos
instances et je termine
rassurez-vous tous les maires sont
représentés du village à la métropole
gauche droite centre dans nos instances
les maires proches du pouvoir don qui
ont des positionnements proche de la
macronie sont très représentés et ils ne
sont pas les plus mou face à la critique
à l'égard d'exécutif je dis au passage
vous avez eu ellisabeth borne hier au
téléphone qu'est-ce que vous vous êtes
dit on a travaillé d'abord on a évoqué
avant de parler du Congrès on a évoqué
longuement le
contexte de la société française he on
discute régulièrement avec Elisabeth
borne avec qui je le répète la relation
est saine voilà clinique et moi je
trouve ça très bien et donc on a évoqué
le tout ce que l'on ressent dans dans la
violence de la
société et puis ensuite on a parlé des
d'avancé techniques sur la condition
d'exercice du ma puisque nous
travaillons sur les conditions
d'exercice des m vous savez a que
Dominique fort a mais ça veut dire
qu'elle vous a promis des
choses on est entre adultte
donc non mais vous savez ce qu'elle va
vous annoncer je pas encore complètement
mais il y a des points moi sur lesquels
je lui ai dit voilà nos lignes rouges
voilà nos attentes en terme de c'est
tout ce qui est recentr
tion on est dans enfin on a eu de
l'expérience tous les trois autour de ce
plateau ça fait quand même combien de
fois qu'on entend des annonces d'acte de
décentralisation puis qu'en réalité on
recentralise nos finances on est soumis
à des procédures croissantes enfin et et
tous les maires vous le diront donc ça
je dit qu'il fallait vraiment maintenant
passer à autre chose et y compris
au-delà de la décentralisation sur la
déconcentration des services de l'État
on est convenu d'ailleurs de de position
assez proche là-dessus mais il faut que
passer aux actes qu'on voulait des actes
voilà et puis ensuite il y a des points
techniques sur les communes nouvelles
sur les FCT TVA avec des avancées qui
sont qui sont pour le coup intéressantes
ouis bon mais elle elle fera des
annonces jeudi je c'est pas moi de le
dire non mais c'est comprenez bien c'est
maant de le dire c'est pas Mo on va
parler des inondations Jean-Baptiste oui
les Haut- de- France sont aujourd'hui
soumis quand même à des inondations à
des tempêtes monstres il y a une
question qui se pose sur le plan des
assurances c'estd les compagnies
d'assurance font flamber ces derniers
mois les les tarifs on voit un certain
nombre de de résiliation unilatéral de
contrat de de commune est-ce que les
assurances seront rendez-vous de
l'indemnisation dans les Haut- de-
France selon vous j'en sais pas plus que
vous sur ce rendez-vous sera-t-il honoré
ou pas pr assurance ce que vous dites
est vrai non seulement sur les
résiliations
unilatérales sur tout ce qui est
protection des biens hein euh mais
également sur des franchises j'ai des
exemples de communes où la franchise est
passé de 2000 de 2500 € à 2 million
d'euros j'en ai eu plusieurs de communes
vous vous imaginez c'est que vous n'êtes
pas remboursé jusqu'à 2 millions d'euros
de dégâts des communes de quelle taille
alors là en l'occurrence c'est une
commune de 6000 habitants parce que je
gère le maire m'a écrit à ce sujet et
mais j'ai eu des une commune aussi en
région parisienne qui fait 40000
habitants donc ça transcende un peu les
les les tailles de commune et puis des
polices d'assurance des des des des
cotisations qui elles aussi sont
exponentielles le le problème c'est que
les le Code des Assurances est très très
rigide nous avons de demandé j'avais
alerté Bruno Lemer qui qui a répondu
tout de suite en l'occurrence pour que
on essaie quand même d'élargir la
mission du médiateur des assurance qui
très souvent se déclare incompétent par
rapport au au au contentieux entre les
communes et les assurances je conseille
aux communes de faire appel à un expert
d'assuré le problème c'est qu'il faut
pouvoir se le payer mais moi j'ai été
confronté à des risques majeurs avec des
dégâts colossaux et c'est ce qui nous a
permis d'obtenir un bon recouvrement et
nous travaillons sur un plan B qui pour
faire ressortir un plan A essayer de
stimuler la prise en compte de nos
préoccupations par les assureurs qui eux
sont face à des réalités cotisation
sinistr tout simplement mais un plan B
avec des systèmes de solidarité
d'assurance entre entre collectivités
mais le chef de l'État quand il est allé
dans les haut de France il a annoncé 50
millions pour les aider les collectivité
c'est à la hauteur je peux pas vous le
dire je peux pas vous le dire parce que
on n pas encore non pas que je suis très
impliqué he sur cette question on a été
dès les premières heures très solidaires
par la MF mais aussi par la ville de
canne puisque j'ai envoyé une équipe sur
place avec des spécialistes d'inondation
qui sont restés une semaine sur place
pour aider les populations et les
mersres mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas
encore une évaluation fiable des des
dégâts je puis vous dire que les dégâts
seront bien supérieurs à ce montant
après les comptes de l'État sont ce
qu'ils sont aussi hein on va parler des
violences envers les élus et des
agressions Jean-Baptiste oui le nombre
d'agressions physique augmente on
regarde 2021 2022 2023 ça ne cesse de de
de flamber on a vu aussi évidemment cet
été les attaque contre les hôtels de
ville une centaine une centaine
d'attaques de de quoi cette violence
est-elle le
nom de la décivilisation voilà les même
mot qu'Emmanuel Macron enfin disons que
Emmanuel Macron prend le même mot que
ceux qu'on utilisait il y a quelques
mois quelques années même avec notamment
le professeur berger Maurice Berger le
pédopsychiatre ou avec na Fadel
spécialiste et on avait écrit d'ailleurs
des papiers en commun et surtout un
terme qui vient de Norbert Elias dans
les années 30 et c'est pas pour rien
hein norber observer la montée des
fascismes des nazismes et des
totalitarismes et parler de de tous ces
liens de de quotidien de d'éducation de
civilité qui se délitait et je me
permets de dire aussi que avec mon
coauteur Jean-Michel Arnaud nous avions
écrit un livre il y a plusieurs années
j'avais d'ailleurs été invité ici qui
s'appelait refaire communauté pour en
finir avec l'inciivisme ont évoquit ces
phénomènes qui sont ceux de c'est très
c'est si vous voulez il y il y a des il
y a des choses immédiates c'est que
l'impuissance publique euh la la la la
défaillance régalienne le crée de
l'injustice et et on accepte tout SAF
l'injustice dans dans dans dans la vie
hein mais le fait que la moitié des
peines ne sont pas exécutées au au bout
de 2 ans qui a un côté arbitraire parce
que il y a une pénurie de moyen dans la
justice même s'il y a eu des des effort
ces dernières années mais c'est bien
loin du compte et ça ça renvoie à
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics donc
ça c'est presque de l'immédiat c'est
structurel mais c'est l'organisation des
pouvoirs publi notre crise de la
démocratie quiévoqué Laurent Berger
parce qu'il avait raison nous sommes une
crise de la démocratie c'est avant tout
une crise de l'exécution une crise de
l'impuissance publique mais il y a des
phénomènes beaucoup plus puissants qui
viennent de on va pas faire l'histoire
et la sociologie bien qu'il faud en
faire tout le temps VI le 14-18 viennent
du nihilisme de l'Occident et je crois
qu'on est un virage je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on sent bien que soit il
y a une décadence un effondrement moral
soit A un redressement moral
comportemental et c'est pourquoi il faut
porter un discours puissant sur la
République française parce que la la clé
elle est là il est pas assez puissant
aujourd'hui le discours qui est porté
bah non parce que vous voyez moi je
croyais que moi j'adore la la
confrontation d'idées même parfois avec
insolence enfin je trouve que ça fait
partie d'ailleurs de l'esprit français
euh et je je pense qu'il faut retrouver
un clivage droite gauche pour parfois le
transcender mais pour qu'il y ait une
vra des vraies alternatives des vrais
choix avec des curseurs entre liberté et
égalité je pense que c'est ce qui est le
plus pertinent mais quand on voit qu'une
partie de la classe politique de gauche
d'extrême gauche en l'occurrence qui
avant était quand même garante à gauche
du mérite de l'esprit républicain
j'évoqué tout à l'heure se fourvoie
complètement enfin je je ce qui est en
train de se passer autour de Jean-Luc
méchon pour parler honnêtement et quand
même un renversement majeur avec un
parfois des des pensées qui y a une vous
savez la convergence des luttes elle a
laissé place à l'intersectionnalité et
ben c'est c'est pas mieux c'est même
pire c'est-à-dire ce mélange de wisme de
racialisme de
décolonialisme qui part sur une des
condamnations systémiques ce qui veut
pas dire grandchose mais on pour en
parler longuement moi ça me passionnent
ces sujets et qui vont en connexion avec
l'islamisme antisémite et cetera bah ça
donne cette espèce d'extrême gauche très
violente avec un une pensée qui est qui
est totalitaire donc très dur à contrer
et qui porte atteinte à la République
mais qui est quand même très répandu 18
% on dit c'est c'est rejeté par 92 % des
Français 18 % c'est énorme ça permet de
faire un second tour de présidentiel he
voilà vous êtes inquiet de nouvelles
émeutes vous l'avez dit hier les
réponses apportées par Elisabeth born et
son gouvernement ça veut dire qu'elles
sont pas les bonnes les bonnes les
bonnes B la su oui c'est c'est comme ça
c'est on le fait tous euh non mais mais
il y a des choses intéressantes he sur
notamment les violences qui sont liés
aux émeutes mais les effets du des
réseaux sociaux et du numériques parce
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure de violence
physique sur les élus moi beaucoup
d'élus me parlent de de de la de la
souffrance qu'ils peuvent ressentir à
l'égard des violences qui sont
symboliques mais réelles notamment du
dénigrement sur les réseaux sociaux des
attaques sur les familles c'est des
choses qui reviennent de plus en plus et
c'est lié à ce phénomène d'émeut et de
d'élitement civique qu'on nous évoquions
à l'instant donc il y a eu des des
éléments importants mais moi je mais ça
c'est pas la MF qui parle c'est moi
enfin si j'ai créé un parti s'appelle
nouvelle énergie si on travaille sur
l'organisation des pouvoirs publics je
pense qu'il faudra un renversement
complet dans dans dans dans
l'organisation de des pouvoirs public et
que on est dans un système
de social étatiste qui qui a à bout de
souffle voilà mais parmi les réponses
àortter il y a donner plus de pouvoir
aux policiers municipaux est-ce que
c'est ce qu'il faut
faire je vais peut-être vous surprendre
mais à titre personnel je suis très
attaché moi au modèle régalien et et de
l'État sur le plan judiciaire autant je
pense qu'il faut que la subsidiarité
soit la règle c'estd qu'en fait le local
puisse faire tout ce qu'il entend mais
sur ce qui relève de la Justice de la
police je pense que ça doit rester le
monopole de l'État sauf que dans la
réalité ça ne marche plus dans la
réalité et notamment en zone police les
polices municipales sont les Primot
intervenantes
sont enfin sont sont indispensables et
il est vrai que elles n'ont pas de
pouvoir d'enquête zéro pouvoir d'enquête
c'est comme ça que lorsque vous savez il
y avait eu le forfait de verbalisation
sur les stupes ça a été retoqué par le
Conseil constitutionnel donc on est dans
un système
intermédiaire et
la tout ce qui peut nous donner plus
d'efficacité pour faire du contrôle
d'identité pour faire des fouilles pour
s'attaquer au dealer sera le bienvenu
mais ça voudra dire qu'il faudra sans
sans créer des mares qui soient des
Chérif parce qu'il a aussi cette
tentation chez certains qu'il faut
absolument balayer que les polices
municipales ne deviennent pas les su
de l'État et c'est tout le rapport entre
les
parquets le commissaire le préfet et les
maires la police municipale doit rester
sous l'autorité du maire et c'est tout
le la difficulté de trouver le bon
curseur de l'autorité judiciaire dans
durant ces émeutes il y a des maies des
écoles qui ont été dégradées on 168
écoles jamais des écoles n'avaient été
attaquées dans l'histoire de France he
moi j'ai recherché j'en ai parlé des
historiens non mais pardonnez-moi vous
mais ça revient à ce qu'on disait sur la
dibilisation c'est ni sous la front ni
sous la Révolution française ni en 1830
ni en 1848 ni dans les années 30 avec
les mouvements fascistes il n'y avait eu
des écoles attaquées voilà c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose qui doit nous
obséder on en est où de la
reconstruction écoutez alors j'ai
certaines écoles ont été reconstruit
d'autres non il y a des écoles
provisoires j'ai j'ai vu des mes des
ivelines en début de semaine dernière
qui qui m'ont fait part de difficultés
bon en tout cas il y a il y a une
réponse à à appter aux enfants en terme
de bâtiment les les problèmes très
souvent dans les écoles aujourd'hui
c'est pas les bâtiments même dans les
communes où les écoles ont été détruites
c'est parfois les absences
d'enseignants qui ne dépendent pas des
maires sur la réponse judiciaire Jean-M
est-ce qu'elle est la hauteur selon vous
la la réponse judiciaire je crois que
vous réclamez au-delà peut-être même de
la réponse judiciaire un nouvel
arsenal juridique législatif
réglementaire la priorité c'est de
verire exécuter les lois existantes euh
ensuite il faut des évolutions
législatives mais la priorité parce
qu'il y a eu toujours le cas non ah non
mais c'est même trop rarement le cas il
y a eu une bonne réponse judiciaire
c'est-à-dire que les instructions qui
avaient été données à la police à la
gendarmerie par par le ministre de
l'Intérieur et à la au magistrat dans le
respect de l'indépendance des magistrats
mais par le Garde des SA ont été bonnes
et il y a eu objectivement les tribunaux
ont bossé avec des condamnation le
problème c'est l'exécution des peines et
dans la réalité avant même de parler
d'évolution législative et j'ai des
propositions à la matière mais c'est on
se rend compte que en France on adapte
mais c'était le cas sur le covid c'est
le cas sur beaucoup de choses la
doctrine la pénurie regardez pour les
actes les plus graves ceux qui
nécessitent de protéger la société donc
de mettre en prison pas de mettre tout
le monde en prison parce que je mais de
en respectant la graduation des peines
on a ce paradoxe français qui illustre
beaucoup de nos paradoxes y compris sur
la dépense publique et les prélèvement
obligatoire et l'endettement ce paradoxe
français de avoir un une surpopulation
carcérale ce qui est absolument indigne
d'une grande démocratie des prisonniers
parfois trois ou quatre en prison dans
la même cellule ce qui est absolument
anormal et digne on se fait épingler à
juste titre par des associations
spécialisées mais parallèlement d'avoir
un sousaux d'incarcération on est
nettement dessous de la moyenne
nationale et des juges d'application des
peines qui en raison de cette pénurie et
des conditions indignes en fait ne font
pas appliquer les peines donc des voyou
certains vont en prison d'autres pas
pour les mêmes condamnations donc c'est
de l'arbitraire c'est de l'injustice et
on ne protège pas la société ensuite sur
le plan législatif il faut absolument
revoir le code de justice pénale des
mineurs qui a remplacé l'ORD de 45 et
avec Alexandre Martin député nous avons
fait une proposition et le professeur on
s'inspirait de de ce qu'a fait des
travaux du professeur berger je CITIS
tout à l'heure pédopsychiatre pour
retrouver de la responsabilité
individuelle qui est la seule réponse à
l'insécurité Jean-Baptiste sur les
indemnités oui les indemnités des élus
on a interviewé à à la Gazette des
communes le président du Medef qui se
montre favorable à une hausse des
indemnités dans dans dans quelle ampleur
il faudrait augmenter ses indemnités et
question subsidiaire aussi est-ce que
c'est possible d'augmenter les les
indemnités au moment où beaucoup de nos
comptecitoyens souffrent quand même d'un
pouvoir d'achat amputé par l'inflation
alors de deux choses d'abord c'est pas
la première demande des élus hein et
d'ailleurs l'enquête du svipof le
démontre euh la la première le premier
malêtre des des des élus locaux des élus
communaux vient de la difficulté
croissante à agir donc ce qui se
retrouve dans le fait que on disent trop
d'attente de la part des administrés
difficultés de relation avec l'État et
c'était le thème du du Congrès l'année
dernière mais aujourd'hui on continue
d'ailleurs c'est le pouvoir agir ça
c'est vraiment la base comment on peut
faire vivre la démocratie locale et donc
pouvoir décider agir rendre des comptes
à nos habitants deuxièmement la
démocratie n'a pas de prix mais elle a
un coout et euh le les quand il il est
absolument anormal que plus de la moitié
des maires de France perdent de l'argent
en devenant maire parce que c'est la
réalité beaucoup cumulent avec un job
hein notamment dans les petites communes
euh qui reprentent le tissu
majoritaire des communes de France et
l'indemnité elle est de inférieure au
SMIC nettement inférieure au SMI hein et
c'est pas normal et et ça on peut le
regarder en face c'estd que beaucoup de
compatrioc compris de ceux qui galèrent
d'abord pensent que les Mair gagnent
beaucoup plus sont très surpris du
montant de laadimité notamment dans les
petites communes et c'est c'est
complètement marginal en terme de
dépenses et aujourd'hui il faudrait
qu'un maire qui a une fonction exécutive
une responsabilité civile politique et
pénale et la CAPAC et et un revenu de au
moins de cadres moyen quoi enfin c'est
ne soit pas perdant parce que ça
contribue à dévaloriser cette fonction
qui est pourtant la plus belle de la
République française il y a un nombre
record de déémissions de Mair et de
conseillers municipau 40 par mois de
Mair rien que les maires c'est 40 par
mois en moyenne est-ce que vous craignez
vous alertez sur une crise d'é voocation
pour
2026 nous sommes encore le pays où il y
a le plus de vocation parce qu'on a ce
tissu de de commune qui est unique et
qui est une richesse à tous les sens du
terme d'ailleurs euh mais oui oui parce
que vous savez j'en discute avec des
maires et c'est pas que dans des
villages dans des villages parfois on a
du mal à boucler la liste en plus il y a
un problème de surreprésentation c'estàd
que le le le nombre d'élus par rapport
au nombre d'habitants est demandé dans
les conseils municipaux est beaucoup
plus fort dans les villages donc ça il
faut qu'on le revoit il y a beaucoup de
sénateurs qui travaillent là-dessus
d'ailleurs à juste titre mais même dans
les grandes villes mais y compris à
Paris moi j'ai discuté avec des
représentants de grands partis hein de
partis majoritaires en France qui ont du
mal parfois à boucler des listes de
qualité équilibré et cetera dans des
grands arrondissements donc il peut y
avoir un problème de vocation mais y
compris dans les très grandes villes
est-ce que la fin du cumule des mandats
étaé une erreur j'ai j'ai écoutez
jusqu'à une date très récente je disais
que je ne savais pas euh mais
aujourd'hui je crois que oui c'était une
erreur faut revenir dessus bah oui parce
qu'on ser d'abord paradoxalement ça
coûtait moins cher à la République pour
des raisons mécanique et technique qu'on
pourrait évoquer et puis ça permettait
quand même d'avoir moins cette affron
entre le pouvoir central et le pouvoir
local ça permettait juste d'avoir une
meilleure représentation des aspirations
du terrain au Sénat et à l'Assemblée
bien que le Sénat il y a encore beaucoup
d'élus qui a une expérience locale et
mais ça permettait aussi auprès des
maires de mieux comprendre les
difficultés du pouvoir centrale on va
parler un mot sur une question des
finances et et impôts oui les impôts une
note récente de
Terranova propose préconise un nouvel
impôt local c'est une proposition qui
est soutenue par un certain nombre de
d'association d'élu est-ce que est-ce
que vous la la soutenez après la la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation je
vais vous répondre très clairement mais
vous me permettrez de de
contextualiser non non parce que notre
pays est le pays qui a le record du
monde des prélèvements obligatoire he
impôt et charge on est on se tire la
Bour avec Dannemark mais on est passé
devant on est à 46 % d'impôt de charge
première remarque deème remarque vous
serez d'accord avec moi pour dire que
plus l'État a supprimé des impôts locaux
taxes prof professionnel taxe
d'habitation désormais CV plus nous
payons de prélèvement en tant que
Français parce que si on avait supprimé
les impôts locaux qu'on avait perdu
l'autonomie mais qu'au moins on avait
une démonstration de la capacité
d'augmentation de l'efficacité de la
puissance publique c'est le contraire
trème élément il le système aujourd'hui
est hypocrite ne peut plus
fonctionner l'exécutif ça été très vrai
ces dernières années nous a mis sous
perfusion du malade en terme de compte
public qui est l'état qui Emprin pour
son fonctionnement qui est surendetté et
cetera et ensuite on dit regardez ces
maires ah ils se plaignent de l'État
mais ils demandent toujours des
notations ben oui aujourd'hui si vous
voulez que l'argent revienne à ceux à
qui il appartient c'est au contribuables
locaux donc on est au bout d'un système
qui en plus est opaque le manque de
démocratie que celui de la dotation et
je pense que il faudra un jour avec
maturité dans un contexte je l'espère
d'amélioration du fonctionnement de la
puissance publique qui permettra de
baisser les prélèvements obligatoires
qui pèsent sur les Français et les
entreprises et les ménages mais d'avoir
un impôt résidentiel parce que il est
inefficace et injuste de faire reposer
l'effort fiscal local que sur les
propriétaires ce qui est le cas ce qui
est le cas pardon aujourd'hui et
l'augmentation de la dotation globale de
fonctionnement c'est pour la deuxè année
consécutive ça vous suffit pas là aussi
c'est que on dit on serait prêt à
accompagner cela si on n disait pas vous
devez vous esbaudir parce que c'est
historique c'est ce qu'on entend depuis
de jour comme l'année
dernière quand la DGF n'évoluait pas
avec l'inflation mais que l'inflation
était à 1,5 et que ensuite la DGF évolue
de 0,8 mais que l'inflation est à 4 % on
est encore plus perdant en euro constant
c'est tout et au passage c'est un
prélèvement de l'État parce que les
dynamiques jusqu'à maintenant en tout
cas les recettes de l'État étaient
dynamiqu au moins de l'inflation
notamment sur la TVA donc c'est une
captation de ressources locales lorsque
ce n'est pas stable en euro constant un
mot sur la mission verte Jean-Baptiste
oui juste une dernière petite question
si vous permettezien sur les sur les
finances publiques parce que vous dites
que la France est championne d'Europe
des prélèvements obligatoire du monde
pardon euh et vous dites également qui
dit hein c'est l'INC c'est réité vous
dites aussi régulièrement que la France
a 3000 milliards de dettes est-ce
qu'elle peut se permettre d'indexer les
dotations versé aux collectivités sur
l'inflation comme vous le souhaitez à
l'association des Mr de France parce que
ça va être encore des dépens supp 3054
milliards et si et si on regarde le hors
bilan dont on parle jamais c'est 6000
milliards de dettes c'est bien plus que
tous les actifs de l'État donc la
situation est bien pire que ça
deuxièmement c'est un un un détournement
d'opinion que de penser que le problème
des comptes de de de public vient de la
relation entre l'État et les
collectivités on parle de 200 300
millions d'euros et pendant ce temps-là
on ne parle pas des 34 % de dépenses de
public sur le le le social on ne parle
pas d'un État qui a dépeuplé ses
préfectures et ses sous-préfectures vous
avez lu le rapport de la Cour des
comptes et qui pourtant augmente encore
ses fonctionnaires sur les fonctions
purement administrantes à cause de
l'excès de normes de règles tout tout ce
que Jean-Pierre jouillet au
fonctionnaire si il en est avou une fois
qu'il est à la retraite en disant ce
qu'ait ce qu'on traité de populiste
avait raison j'ai eu quel hommage dire
voilà et à postériori j'allais dire
autre chose donc donc si vous voulez
tout ça c'est quand face au défi de
notre époque le défi écologique le défi
numérique la solution elle vient dans le
local dans une certaine mesure et
aujourd'hui si on ne peut plus bouger ça
coûte plus cher à la fin à l'état ce
système est infernal ce système est
abominable et moi je veux pas en tant
que maire passer ma vie à réclamer des
moyens à l'état en sachant que ces
moyens appartiennent sont censés
appartenir aux collectivité la parole de
l'État historique lorsque la patente
avait été supprimée puis la
décentralisation eu lieu puis la réforme
la suppression de taxe d'habitation
c'était on vous on vous rembourse à
l'époque au franc prê à l'euro pr en
euro constant c'est tout ce que nous
rappelons deux questions sur les
républicains pour terminer David Lisnard
Emmanuel Macron vendredi avait convié
les chefs de parti au deuxè R compte de
Saint-Denis pour parler er il est passé
à la trappe c'est ça Eric ver du coup et
du coup il est passé à la
TR Eric soti ne s'est pas rendu à ces
rencontres de Saint- est-ce que c'est
responsable quand on est un parti de
gouvernement de pratiquer la politique
de la chass vide bah écoutez vu ce qui
est sorti de ces rencontres de saint-d
je pense que je je je lui ferai pas
grief de ne pas avoir voulu figurer être
un figurant dans une niè séquence de com
mais il est sorti un abandon du
référendum sur l'immigration qu'Emmanuel
Macron était prêt à accepter est-ce que
att si on est à ce niveau d'immaturité
de relation parce que tu viens pas
j'abandonne quelque chose qui serait
possible pour le pays il faut poser la
question président de la République là
c'est le problème il est là il est pas
ailleurs il y avait quand même me
semble-t-il rassemblement national donc
le rassemblement national s'est assis
sur le le un référendum sur
l'immigration c'est ça il y a eu un
accord donc de ceux qui étaient présents
y compris le rassemblement national sur
l'abandon de la seule façon d'échapper à
la contrainte
jurisprudentielle de la Cour européenne
des droits de l'homme qui rend
inopérante toutes les mesures qu'on peut
annoncer ici ou là en terme de maîtrise
des flux migratoire ça c'est faute c'est
faute d'accord des participants est-ce
qu'ericti n'aurait pas dû aller défendre
défendre ça devanton parle de
l'absenceicotti il faut quand même
parler de de ce qui n'est pas sorti
d'ailleurs de de une fois de plus de de
de de cette de cette séquence le mot
séquence est approprié de donc qui voilà
l'abandon soit il faut faire référendum
pour pour maîtriser les flux migratoires
ce que chacun pense al il y a ceux qui
sont qui pensent que c'est pas un vrai
problème bon nous on pense que c'est un
problème donc aujourd'hui hélas hein le
le problème de l'immigration massive est
devenu un problème massif pour le pays
bon et et on sait très bien que tout ce
que l'on peut débattre au Sénat et à
l'assemblée sera très peu opérationnel
si on ne retrouve pas de la capacité
d'action qui passe par un un référendum
pour faire évoluer la Constitution donc
voilà donc soit c'est bon pour le pays
soit c'eston pour le pays le reste n'est
que théâtre merci David merci beaucoup
d'avoir été notre invité merci
Jean-Baptiste merci à vous de votre
intérêt pour tout ce que l'on fait dans
ce événement qui est unique au monde
quand même le Congrès des mares c'est
tous mes prédécesseurs qui ont su
construire ça les françois Barouin les
JAC Pissard les de vois donc c'est
quelque chose de fantastique le Congrès
des mes et on le suivra bien sûr toute
la semaine sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
et on va parler de l'enquête du CDP tout
de suite dans le club des territoires